and if you are looking for activities to
enjoy before school starts back up
we have a wild option for you and the
family world lion day is coming up and
the lion habitat ranch is celebrating
all weekend rocky's there live to get a
preview
of what to expect rocky how's it going
out there
hello from the lion habitat ranch denise
our zookeeper here
is helping us feed bella right now have
you guys ever fed a lion
if not you can do it here okay so you
ready ready
so bella i'm not afraid by the way you
have to be calm so go ahead and set the
meatball right here you set the look at
that
set the meatball how much do they eat so
the females that eat anywhere between
five and seven and a half pounds a day
and the males will eat anywhere between
seven and a half and twelve pounds a day
they eat a lot of food
although bella will tell you she's never
eaten a day in her life i feel like she
likes extra food oh yeah this is loving
las vegas now right now she's like thank
you guys
okay wow that was that was not scary
that was actually invigorating it was
very exciting
okay so tell us about bella so bella is
14 years old
usually lions will live about 7 to 12
years in the wild and about 15 to 20
years in human
care all right we got one more meatball
bella come on bella
i don't know if you know this about
lions but they naturally like to
roll another animal's poop to disguise
their smell like a cologne wow
okay that's different didn't know that
so what so they roll around and poop and
we spray ourselves with cologne
a little fun fact there okay so for
rural lion day which is next tuesday
we're celebrating here at lion habitat
ranch
this weekend saturday and sunday what do
you what can the community expect what
can families do this weekend
so they'll actually be able to do a
scavenger hunt to learn about
lions and then also if you're 14 or
under you can dress up as a lion and you
can actually win
a lion feeding experience which is what
you just did that is so cool and of
course it's all about enrichment and
taking care of the lions here i just
want to let you guys know
this right here we're gearing up to wash
the lions premium care
oh yeah so we do bathe our lions here
all right so come on down this weekend
saturday sunday from 10 a.m to 2 p.m all
right i'll send it back to you
such beautiful creatures thank you rocky
las vegas now we'll be right